I've seen things
I can't explain
and I've come to believe it's not so
much what you believe
it's how hard you believe Hello
everybody I am Fandango correspondent
Nikki Novak and I am so excited to be
talking about this incredible film on
this the the day that the tickets have
just gone on sale and I'm talking about
Indiana Jones and the dial of Destiny in
theaters on June 30th so pleased to be
talking to you both thank you thank you
so much for the time so let's dig in
pardon the pun
um first
oh no I already have an eye roll here we
go this film is set in the 1960s 10
years since we last Saw Indiana Jones
and I've heard that maybe you said he
was he's very much a fish out of water
in this situation so how have
the times changing and time affected
India as this film opens as this film
opens and by the and it opens in the
past to start with we have a the usual
teaser or first sequence of the films
sometimes has something to do with the
movie sometimes it doesn't in this case
it does have to do to the movie and it's
me during World War II and I've been
de-aged yes and that was done with a new
technology that I don't think has ever
been used before except in deep fakes
they have used all of the footage that
lucasfilm has acquired from since I
started working with them and many many
years ago 35 40 Years of footage of me
not only the takes that were used but
the footage that wasn't used
and they're able to mine that for
for my face in different lights and with
different Expressions then I do a act
the scene with balls on my face
have a device for animation
but in this case they're able to go
through all of this stock footage that
they have of me and pick out those
moments when I was that age 35 years and
old or so and my lips are coming from
the performance with the balls on my
face but the rest of my face is is my
actual face from 35 years ago so it's
not like a kind of
what do they call it Photoshop kind of
thing it's uh it's really my face so
it's spooky the first time this has ever
really happened in a sense and I think
you know fans of Indiana Jones customers
know that that's really quintessential
Indie is when you have that opening
sequence so for people who are excited
to see this film how big a Thrill Ride
is that opening sequence going to be I
think it's great I mean I think our
script all together is fantastic but
that opening is of course action-packed
and then the cut from that to present
day the day that men landed on the moon
is a is a great transition
and we get to see Indiana Jones at my
age on his last day of being a professor
at Hunter College he's retiring from
that and he's not not in the best shape
of his life when he meets uh Phoebe I
want to talk a little bit first about
your entry point in the franchise I know
that there was a dinner there was an
offer there was a little bit of wine
ordered and then there was a script how
fantastic was the wine and how fantastic
was the script I don't remember anything
about the Kathy asking me about it and
then and then the wine I couldn't
believe how quickly I read that script A
scripts are hard to read anyway even if
they're good because it's just the focus
element is always just a little bit hard
and that I sat down with that script and
it felt like five minutes had gone by
and I was just it's breathless and it's
so exciting and that opening sequence
um is and I was laughing out loud and
gasping I just even just reading the
script I felt so in the world already
and it was just I could not wait to get
started and I came the first day on set
I actually came and I saw you shooting
that stuff
um when you're in the 1944 Series yeah
I'm not sure how much I can give away
but you're um in a compromising
situation so I saw you shoot all that
stuff and then having seen the film see
the de-aging thing which so impressive
technologically but it's also really
impressive that you were actually still
the person doing all that crazy stuff
one another quintessential thing about
Indie is not only his Adventure but who
he goes on the adventure with from kiwei
Quan to the late great Sean Connery my
favorite actor of all time the
partnership in camaraderie is so
important so when they meet each other I
know there's a Godfather goddaughter
situation how do they feel about each
other like how does she see him and how
does he see her is he kind of like the
uh you know oh that's just my great you
know my godfather or well the last time
he saw her as she was 12 years old and
she is the she is Indiana Jones god
daughter
her father is a former associate of mine
wonderful English actor named Toby Jones
plays her father then she shows up and I
I don't recognize her because she's
taller and looks different and she's
showing up at Hunter College of course
she's up to no good but I don't know
that at the time well I understand that
your character is perhaps there's an
inspiration James mangle gave to you and
it was Barbara Stanwick a character from
the 1940s and that this character she's
a little bit crafty she's very very
Charming but she's a bit of a catalyst
and a little bit of trouble so how does
that Dynamic work between the two of
these characters am I correcting in my
yeah yeah totally she's um she's very
manipulative and that's fun to play all
those layers but she's definitely
playing the little emotional violin when
she meets Indy for the first time
reminding him of showing him photographs
reminding him of the um kind of idyllic
times they spent when they were younger
and kind of bringing him into this sort
of soft focus this memory just long
enough so that she can spin on him and
get what she wants from him because she
is she's a Survivor and she's smart and
she seems to be one of those people who
has been kind of trading on luck most of
her life and at the beginning of the
film you discover that she she's getting
a little squeaky it feels like her luck
is running out so she's had to pull all
the stops out and one of the stops she
had to pull out in order to save herself
from this terrible situation she's got
herself into is to hit up her old
Godfather and try and um manipulate
something out of his possession
so she is very much the Catalyst in this
in this situation
um I haven't seen the film obviously
I've seen a trailer where you have a
line where you say those days have come
and gone in terms of your adventure it
seems like maybe he's been a little bit
heavy on the Academia a little light on
the adventure in the past 10 years is
that correct yeah I think he's he has
been teaching for however many years
he's a bit dispirited with the with
teachings his students are not keen on
archeology necessarily
and uh they're kind of loafing through
his classes and I suppose he is as well
and he's now forced to retire right I
suppose the rules at Hunter College and
they're bringing somebody else in uh to
be the head of the archeology Department
and uh he has no real future in mind for
himself wow
like we've seen him before this must add
a layer for you that you found delicious
I thought I thought it would be really
interesting to see him at the end of his
uh career older not necessarily wiser
but uh still capable of a last hurray so
the adventure finds him he doesn't find
the adventure so to speak for you as an
actor we're talking about maybe playing
different layers than you've played
before as Indie he finds himself in a
new situation but the quintessential
stuff that we love to see from Indy the
facial expressions the physicality that
type of a thing can you talk about
revisiting that character and any joy
that you found in that
well yeah I mean there's great joy in
playing the character I'm familiar with
the character I've enjoyed playing the
character I've had great writing to
support the character's Behavior and the
sense of who he is but now we're taking
him into the Twilight of his life and
his career
we're seeing him not so strong not so
brave not so attentive but about to go
on a Grand Adventure with a very
fascinating set of
uh compatriots and uh and adversaries
speaking of Adventure your first time
playing
in an action film was it like a fish out
of water or a fish to water in that
sense very much both
um very much a fish in and out of the
water all the time I feel I was so
excited
um to be a fish in that water and she
killed it she really went for it so much
fun especially because there's it's not
meant to be slick so so allowing the
action to be kind of like a bit rough
and a little bit like you kind of have
to throw yourself into it in a way that
you really don't know what's going to
happen obviously within the safety
protocols and everything but there's
always an element of you're allowed to
mess it up a bit and um and that was
incredibly fun the adrenaline of doing
it like I mean it really felt like
really very real at times and I was
covered in bruises which I loved and and
I just love being sort of yeah flung
around a set like that it was just so
fun and you have to stop acting when
you're doing stunts I mean I was
supposed to keep acting but I was
genuinely thrilled and terrified at the
times that Helena was meant to be
thrilled and terrified but I love it and
I love I have a whole new appreciation
for watching stunts now and uh and a and
an Envy well that leads me into the
James mangle of it all first time
directing an Indiana Jones movie
obviously taking over for Steven
Spielberg I understand you two have been
friends for a long time you've had
dinners together it was perhaps your
suggestion that maybe he would be a
great nominee to come on board and that
he's he insisted on doing a lot of
things practically he did not want to
sound stage he brought you all over the
world you went to Sicily you went to so
many different places a joy and a curse
in terms of the sets and sort of what's
demanded of you in terms of shooting
things practically no I mean we've
always shot things practically as much
as possible and we did the same here Jim
is a perfectionist he's got eyes like a
hawk he works terrifically hard
by himself he works hard with us he
works hard for us and he's uh he's a
terrific director we I had the best time
working with him he's a perfectionist
we're both sort of of that ilk
and so it was a it was delightful
working with him we had a lot of fun
making the movie hanging out together
and Jim
just uh was it was a great time he's
such a chameleon as a director there's a
lot of directors that you know their
stamp but from Walk the Line to 310 to
Yuma to Benford versus Ferrari so what
sort of energy or or different vibe does
Indiana Jones 5 have because of his
contribution Jim developed the story
with the Butterworth brothers who wrote
the script and I was very surprised by
the design of it it uh it's a very
complicated story it's a very intricate
kind of sophisticated construction for
what looks like an easier kind of thing
but it's really well built well
constructed and you know the
cinematography is great the the action
is great it's a huge job of work for for
a director and Jim just worked
tirelessly on it they sometimes the
Blockbusters are the harder ones to make
I think Phoebe I want to ask you about
the McGuffin and the McGuffin is the
dial of Destiny and I know you can't
tell us anything about the dial of
Destiny nor do I want it spoiled but
what can you dial audiences into about
it because I've heard that it is such I
keep hearing the word clever and that
the villains are clever and clever in
this and it's just a brilliant story but
what can you dial us into well it's an
Ode to
um some of the great myths of our time
but also to mathematics and arithmetic
and the potential of human
accomplishment uh no matter what time
history of the world they are
achieving things and it is round
speaking of round
speaking of round we obviously know the
boulder from Raiders of the Lost Ark
there is a shot in the trailer of you
thank you have you I think it's a globe
or something that you tip off what was
the moment for you that you said to
yourself whether it was a callback
an action where you said to yourself I
am really in an Indiana Jones movie I
really think it's once we got into
again I'm not even sure if I can say
this we've gone into a certain set
that had a kind of magic to it and that
was completely all-encompassing the set
was so whichever way you looked you were
really in this place and I walked in
there and we were towards the end of
filming and so much of it these things
were hitting me all the time but it was
really only when I walked into that
particular set that I felt the 10 year
old in me just be like thank you for the
choices you made getting us here because
this was the moment
um that everything felt
um the most magical and pinch me it was
beautiful what was the moment for you
where you said I am back in an Indiana
Jones movie
well I mean all it takes is to put on
the leather jacket the Hat hang a whip
from my belt and look in the mirror and
oh
Indiana Jones it came easy I heard it
came easy well it wasn't hard and it was
fun does he Channel you at this point or
do you Channel him do you feel like I
channel the ideas not the character the
ideas uh that the character is meant to
give uh expression to so I'm looking for
that cement between the character and
the story and I want to make sure that I
make every moment with that character
help the story because that alloy
between character and story when it is
seamless it provides the greatest model
support for both the character and the
story forgive me if is a Cheesy question
but
so many of us look up to our heroes of
film
and the people that we grow up with like
you said the 10 year old in you you're
the only person that knows what it's
like to be in the zone and play that
character can you describe
when you're in the pocket and you're
having a great day or you had a you know
a day on set that everything was just
jiving sort of how does that feel it
feels better in the slap in the belly
with a wet fish
we did you really okay well I said I
said you're one day I feel this feels
better in this lap and the belly with a
white fish and she said what what are
you talking about I said you don't know
that expression slap in the belly with a
wet fish you didn't know it so I we
happened to be in near a wet fish there
were wet fish in the in the vicinity we
were in a Moroccan uh Market
and I got her to slide me in the belly
with a white fish
but to answer your question it was great
pleasure to to play this character I I'm
so grateful for the opportunity that I
had at the beginning of this and the
opportunities that I've had throughout
this experience playing this character I
know what it's it's done
changed my life had great effect on my
life
and I'm very grateful that
um that audiences have enjoyed it we've
had great filmmakers Steven Spielberg
Jim Mangold we've had great actors it's
been an incredible ride uh for 40 years
we've been doing this and I wanted the
last one to be I wanted to be really
good and I think it is is that why you
were emotional because I know you've
been on stage a couple of times either
teasing a photo or a trailer and you
became a little bit emotional oh me yeah
no I'm not emotional
sentimental I'm not sentimental not at
all I mean
made of wood
now of course it means a lot to me I
would love for you to tease a little bit
of the villains mads Mickelson Boyd
Holbrook every Indiana Jones film
there's no two villains that have been
alike how do these how are these
formidable opponents in this story mods
brings he's created a character so
sinister
because of his gentleness I think and I
think that was um something that was
very surprising and and incredible to
watch sort of Bloom on set especially
for someone who's so up for larking
around and having uh and having a laugh
he's genuinely terrifying and Incredibly
still and Boyd who is sort of
on the same team and yet cut from a very
different cloth they're both they're
both really frightening in in their own
ways and there's things the stakes in
the scripture so it's so clever because
the stakes are so different for every
single person and yet the overall
Adventure is keeping everyone at the
same Pace but mads
so hard to say anything without giving
it away can you help me he's a Nazi no
he's
don't say anything else he's
um he's extraordinary and really
frightening and I think there's a lot of
Joy
um to be taken from an excellent villain
played
beautifully accidentally and he he is
that speaking of frightening every
Indiana Jones film there's a snake
there's a bug there's something
terrifying where you initiated in any
way you don't have to I don't want to
know what it is but was there an
initiation of creepiness
that's a creepy crawly moment okay not
the wet fish who knows that was just fun
there's a creepy calling moment yeah and
there is um
there's some Screaming
there's some running
it's running jumping and falling down
and then you nailed it right I feel it
like even from reading it and then
having watched it I feel it delivers on
every single thing you could possibly
Hope from an Indiana Jones movie as well
as being its own story and it doesn't
repeat anything it's done before but it
has the same DNA the Same Heart the same
feeling and
um that is one of the great joys of it I
think because it's its own thing but
there are moments that your just heart
will explode from
how beautifully Jim's consider carved it
if I told 10 year old Phoebe her Destiny
was to be in a
yeah I mean funny enough I think at 10 I
probably would have believed it it's
only when life hits you around the head
and you go you know you reach around
like your teenage like that won't happen
but at 10 I'd be like yeah that sounds
about right I'd be an adventurer yeah in
an Indiana Jones movie and then um and
then it gets real and you think that
will never happen and then magically it
gets real again and if I told you in
1981 Raiders of the Lost Ark to your
destiny was to be playing this character
in 2023 I would have been happy with
that yeah yeah
incredible yeah
I heard emotional the word emotional use
that it's this is going to kick people
in the ass quoting you
uh yeah well you know I think one of the
one of the things that's really fun for
an audience
is to get a little emotional exercise
not just the running jumping and falling
down
but some some of the moments of of
humanity that are actually quite
touching thank you both so much thank
you all for listening I hope this got
you extra excited to watch the movie
tickets are on sale now at Fandango and
Indiana Jones and the dial of Destiny is
in theaters June 30th thank you again
thank you